prey is proving to be a hit for critics
and fans alike but how do indigenous
film reviewers feel about this comanche
woman vs space monster flick since its
premiere on august 5th hulu's prey has
become a welcome example of big budget
filmmaking with authentic native
american representation in addition to
responding favorably to the film's story
critics have praised the film's focus on
indigenous culture with some even
calling it one of the most realistic and
honest period pieces in cinematic
history prey producer jane myers
reportedly poured her heart and soul
into the predator prequel using her
knowledge and experience as a member of
the comanche nation to help construct
scenes and props evidently the cast was
every bit as dedicated in fact pray made
hollywood history before it even hit
hulu by being a big budget franchise
film with a majority indigenous cast
additionally many cast members including
lead star amber mid thunder have spent a
lot of time talking about the sci-fi
thriller's dedication to historical
accuracy according to mid thunder
delivering an accurate representation of
indigenous peoples was of the utmost
importance to her and it seems like the
rest of the crew was similarly invested
so how does the indigenous community
feel about the film now that it's out in
her review of prey film critic and a
tribe called geek founder johnny j
referred to prey as a groundbreaking
achievement for the entire comanche
nation jay who is from the otto missouri
and choctaw tribes of oklahoma wrote it
is so much more than just another
predator movie it is a rare tribute to
the indigenity strength and sheer
stubbornness that has allowed native
people to survive the forces that
threaten our survival
i've been practicing
it's time i'm ready jay pointed out in
her review that the film was originally
intended to be fully shot in comanche
rather than english but director dan
trachtenberg decided to go with two
different versions the main version in
english and a fully dubbed comanche cut
according to jay it's the first film to
be released in both comanche and english
she wrote in her review i highly
recommend only watching the comanche
version of prey it is an incredible
opportunity to watch a movie entirely in
comanche but there's also a lot of humor
and essential nuances that get lost in
the english version expand your horizons
and watch the comanche version the movie
star amber mid thunder is also
apparently a massive fan of the comanche
dubbing she told the digital fix working
with real comanche language speakers and
people who devote their lives to the
preservation of their own language was
the opportunity of a lifetime it's
special in so many ways vincent
schilling founder and editor of native
viewpoint similarly described prey as a
film that manages to represent
indigenous people masterfully while also
holding up as an incredible action film
indeed many critics have said that the
film deserves to be ranked among the
best of the predator movies schilling
wrote i was admittedly nervous in one
sense because as a native american
journalist i have seen my share of
predatory behavior against native
communities in history but due to the
diligence of dan trachtenberg and jane
myers as well as others the film doesn't
come across as though the native
warriors are just cannon fodder
schilling also noted that it was clear
that the producers of the film paid
supreme diligence to the cultural
accuracy of the film he continued for
once as a native man i could actually
relax and enjoy a film without waiting
for the culturally inappropriate bomb to
drop
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i can't
when it came to the interactions with
settlers and non-native peoples
chilling's only complaint for pretty
much the entire movie was that they
seemed like overly clumsy fools but as
you wrote perhaps that was the point if
these writers are any indication it
appears that indigenous critics are huge
fans of prey schilling wrote in his
review the biggest feeling i have
overall is that the film was simply
fantastic shout out to all the cast and
crew for doing an exceptional job you
made this mohawk film reviewer proud
[Music]